when you're a young kid I do think it's
nice to let children be free to like
explore different things I did ballet
and I also did football and I would say
I was a realy tomboy growing up cuz I
have two brothers I was obsessed with
wrestling I actually used to physically
wrestle with my brothers Gideon was
always really nice he never like threw
me down too hard and I refused to wear
the color pink and I was very free to
choose that and I think that's important
as soon as I turned like 21 I just went
straight into my feminine something just
happened I don't know and you just go
you just become a woman it's the same
with young boys like okay if he wants to
try dancing or singing or something
tradition girly or whatever let them do
it I never played with Barbies I played
with action because of my brothers right
but eventually nature does take over
people should be free then to you know
fall in line with that and not think
that that it's bad